foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar the
basics of protein analysis topic 1
fundamental antibodies for Applied
research topic 2 practical
considerations for quantitations and
Western blotting I am Megan Paschal of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Thermo Fisher Scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you're having trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
this webinar is also equipped with
multiple resources found in the resource
window on the right side of your screen
here you can download PDFs visit
relevant URLs and even download today's
PowerPoint presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speakers Dr
Audrey Lim product manager sea and Dr
Anthony Lynn technical sales leader
Dr Audrey and Anthony Lim you may now
begin your presentation
all right thanks Megan Good afternoon
everybody
today uh Audrey and myself we're sharing
on the topics of antibody on for the
applied research
so I'll start by kicking off on the
fundamentals of the antibodies
this is the outline of my presentation
today where I'll start with an
introduction to the antibodies
the different classes and coloniality of
antibodies
then I'll follow up by sharing some of
the antibody based
technique widely used in the research
field
this slide describes the history of
antibody development in the early 1990s
Paul enrich who proposed the side chain
Theory where he helped his eyes that
side chain receptors on cells bind to
and a given pathogen
he was the first to propose a model for
an antibody molecule in which the
antibody was branched
and consisted of multiple sites for
binding to the foreign materials known
as an antigen
for the activation and the complement
pathway bearing was then awarded the
normal price
in the 1901 where for his work on the
serum therapy
later part of the year
antibody engineering technology was
introduced
in the early 1990s where
then it actually led to the application
of the antibodies as important Pharma
biopharmaceutical products
each antibody recognizes one specific
antigen for example an antibody that
recognizes the mumps virus cannot
recognize the meso virus conversely an
antibody that recognizes the meso virus
cannot recognize the mouth virus
this feature is known as antibody
specificity
each B cell or also known as antibody
producing cells
is able to produce one kind of antibody
antibody have different functionality
firstly on neutralization where the
initializing antibodies are known to
bind to viruses as well as other
particles
later part of the year
the complement system was introduced as
part of the immune system that enhances
or complements the ability of antibodies
cells to clear the microbes and also to
damage and also damage cells from an
organism which then promotes
inflammation
as well as they attack the pathogen
cells membrane
phagocytosis
is a cellular process for ingesting and
eliminating particles such as
microorganism foreign substances as well
as Apostolic cells
antibody affinity and ability so
Affinity is defined as the strength
produced by a single epitope interaction
with a peritope on the antibody
antibodies require a high specificity
towards its epitopes
and this is commonly known as you know
low strength
ability
thereby refers to the accumulated
strength of multiple affinities of an
individual non-covivalent binding
interaction such as between a protein
receptor and its ligand
here shows some of the monomeric or
divalent antibodies including the IGG
igd as well as the ige
there are also the multivalent
antibodies which includes the IGM
as well as the IGA
monoclonal antibodies have monovalent
Affinity binding only to the same
epitope
in contrast
polyclonal antibodies bind to the
multiple epitopes and are usually made
up of by several different antibodies
secreting plasma cells
lineages
bisophic antibody molecular antibodies
can also be engineered by increasing the
therapeutic targets of one monoclonal
antibody to two epitopes
some of the features of body antibodies
may include
and the code Lots
mono control antibody recognizes only
one particular protein formed and they
are commonly known to be expensive to
produce
on the contrary polyclonal antibodies
display a lot to lot variability
they are tolerant to small changes in
protein structures and commonly they are
a lot more economical to the cost of
production
antibodies are generated by immunizing
horse animals with an immunogenic
substance immunogen can be full-length
protein protein fragments peptides
whole organisms such as such as a
material or even cells the immunogen of
the antibody will Define which region of
protein or protein antibody binds to
monoclonal antibodies are typically made
using B cells from uh immunized animal
where
which are fuse
to a immortalized cell line to form a
habibidoma that secretes the desired
antibody clone this hepidoma technique
produces highly consistent specific as
well as sensitive monocular antibodies
in large quantity
recombinant antibodies are produced in
vitro by cloning antibodies Gene from an
immune specific heavy and like antibody
chain into high yield expression vectors
these vectors are then introduced into
expression holes such as bacterial yeast
or even mammalian cells to generate the
recommend molecular antibodies
the deduction of antibodies can be done
either by a direct method or an indirect
detection method
direct detection
will include the use of the primary
antibody that's directly conjugated
to a label for example a 404
and this can be used in flows
automatically techniques which is shown
in the figure here
indirect detection
the primary antibody is bound to a label
secondary antibody that has been raised
against the host species of the primary
antibody
indirect methods may also include the
amplification step to increase the
signal intensity
in this case here it's more commonly
used in applications such as Western
blotting Eliza's immunocytochemistry uh
immunohistochemistry as well as flow
system tree
the choice of using a direct or indirect
detection is often prescribed by the
expression level of the target antigen
to visualize the presence of the target
protein secondary antibodies are
conjugated to fluorescent dyes or
protein or
the enzymes they are able to uh induce a
enzymatic reaction produce to produce
some light for detection
labels emit light in the visual range
when accepted by lights
of a slick and a wavelength these are
there are several several available
all with their own expectation and
emission characteristics
are used commonly to detect the presence
of a specific protein or antigen in
cells or even tissues by using
especially antibody against a target of
Interest this permit Downstream
scientific analysis using methodology
such as versatometry immuno fluorescence
as well as immunohistochemistry
immunoblotting is shown on the right or
commonly known as Western blotting uses
the transfer of biological samples onto
a membrane that permeates the detection
of specific antigen or protein samples
using a specific antibody against the
target
our next presenter Dr Audrey Lim will be
sharing further insights into this
technique
shown here are some of the common
applications that are used which
includes firstly immuno precipitation or
IP for short
this is a technique whereby small scale
Affinity verification of the antigen
using a specific antibody that is
immobilized onto a solid support such as
a medical magnetic particle or a agarose
reason
it is used to study both protein
direction as well as protein DNA
interaction
immunop precipitation was first
developed as an adaptation of the
traditional column Affinity
chromatography
event with the idea to isolate just
enough protein or DNA to be able to
measure it by Western blotting or other
semi-quantitative or quantitative assets
methods
an antibody whether it's going to be
monoclonal or polyclonal against a
specific protein is pre-imobilized onto
US insoluble support such as the agarose
or the magnetic beats and then incubated
with the cellular license containing the
target protein
the during the incubation
gentle agitation of the lysit allows the
target protein to bind to the
immobilized antibody
the immobilize immune complexes are then
collected from the lysate delivered from
the support and analyze based on the
nature of the target antigen
So within the notification side effect
we have actually came out of this term
called Advanced verification Tech
whereby antibodies are extensively
tested in our laboratory to confirm the
antibodies specificity in several
experimental setups these include
relative expression of the Target in
tissues or cell lines model enhance or
reduce expression of the target using
chemical treatment
sir name mediated knockdown of the
protein
these experiments are developed to
justify the quantity quality of the
antibody for our customers and to
enhance the customer's experience
shown here are some of the testing
methods that we use commonly to verify
the specificity of our antibodies
this include not out knocked down
cell treatment and you know relative
expression testing
we hope that you are now better equipped
with the tools to take your research to
the next level thermal facial side
effect has a large range of antibodies
for you to select an antibody that suits
your need
for all your research requirements
with this I like to then acknowledge my
colleagues from the North America as
well as India team who have helped to
prepare this materials that I just
presented so it is thank you and I'll
then hand over to my time over to Dr
Audrey Lim for the next part of the
presentation
[Music]
uh thank you Anthony good afternoon
everyone my name is Audrey and I am the
product manager covering the protein
analysis portfolio in the southeast Asia
region and so today for the second topic
I will be taking you through practical
considerations for quantitation in
Western blotting
now along with Eliza's Western blotting
is still one of the most widely
performed protein detection applications
and an estimated of five to eight
million Western blocks are performed
globally each year
so why do people perform Western
blotting
you know Western blotting is useful for
detecting the presence or absence of a
specific protein in a lysate or complex
mixture
and furthermore it can provide a
qualitative and also quantitative
assessment of changes in protein
expression levels in response to stimuli
or interventions
[Music]
Western blotting has become essential
but it is still not loved
ideally we want to achieve the blood on
the left which has high signal intensity
with a linear response to increasing
levels of the target protein
however more often than not we may get
saturated non-linear signals that are
not quantifiable or Worse still blocks
that look very blotchy or bands that are
burnt out
so today our Focus will be on addressing
these issues so that we can get accurate
data for quantitative reporting
[Music]
the problem of trying to get accurate
quantitative data from Western blocks is
many factors can affect the quantitative
results
experimental variations
inconsistent sample and Target
concentrations unequal sample loading
uneven protein transfer saturated
immunopropy and poor detection can give
you misleading results
so in order to tell if a variation in
expression is real
experimental design controls and
normalization needs to
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
workflow is important from the
separation to the transfer and to the
detection
at thermal facial scientific we provide
a wide product portfolio for your
Western blotting needs that are designed
to save you time and improve your
results
some of our products that will transform
your Western blotting experience include
a reliable Precast gel electrophoresis
system
rapid seven minute transfer systems
validated antibodies automated blood
processors
High sensitivity substrates and our
eyebrite imager that supports Multiplex
detection and quantitation
even before beginning the Western
blotting process it is important to
consider how you are preparing your
protein sample
common sample preparation issues include
excess salt High detergent concentration
incorrect license buffer concentration
DNA contamination
incorrect protein load amount and excess
or incorrect reducing agent
of these issues the most common problem
for accurate quantification is using
excess protein load amount
[Music]
let's see what happens with the signal
intensity when too much protein is
loaded
in the figure on the right the dotted
line presents the ideal situation where
the relative intensity of a protein band
shows a linear response with increasing
protein load
and you can see this nice linear
increase in red when we stain for total
protein using thermal facial Scientifics
no stain reagent
however when we look at some of the
commonly used housekeeping proteins like
actin get the H and tubulin you can see
that the signal starts to lose its
linearity at the higher load amount
from the housekeeping proteins then your
in this figure we have performed Western
blotting for acting in hilar lysates and
from left to right we have used varying
concentrations of primary and secondary
antibodies
as you can see in the corresponding
graphs below the Bloods antibody
concentration has minimal impact on the
Curve
and this means that no matter how much
you optimize your antibody
concentrations it will have little
Improvement to the linearity if the
membrane is already saturated due to
overloading of proteins
[Music]
so for a good Western blood experiment
it is always important to bear in mind
the sample load amount
the amount of protein you load will
influence everything Downstream
including your transfer results
and antibody concentrations to use and
also the detection reagent to choose
too much protein can cause some of the
excess to blow through the membrane
during transfer or fail to bind to the
membrane affecting the accuracy of your
data
during immunodection
too much protein can cause protein bound
to the membrane to be buried and not
accessible to the antibodies
true
so limit your sample load amount based
on abundance of your protein of Interest
High abundance proteins tend to saturate
with loads as low as one to three
micrograms while low abundance proteins
may be linear with up to 40 micrograms
of lysate
for most western blots we recommend
loading 1 to 10 micrograms of lysate and
for low abundance proteins increasing to
5 to 30 micrograms may be appropriate
but not required
thank you
another consideration for quantitation
and linearity of Western blood results
is primary and secondary antibody
concentrations used
too much primary can cause non-linear
antibody binding due to interference
too much primary or secondary antibody
can cause High background which limits
your limit of detection
too much secondary antibody can result
in substrate burnout or non-linear light
production due to the enzyme kinetics
too little secondary can reduce the
dynamic range by limiting the limit of
detection or result in excessive
exposure times required
recommended antibody dilution from
vendors are just general guidelines and
often better results can occur outside
of the recommended range
Street used
as such
antibody concentration optimization is
important to ensure proper signal
higher concentration of antibody does
not always mean better results even when
working with low abundance targets
too much secondary can quickly saturate
your signal especially with high
sensitivity substrates
on the right you can see some
undesirable effects that may be caused
by using the incorrect antibody
concentrations
in the first block at the top the very
high background is likely because too
much primary or secondary antibody was
used
or exposure time was too long
or a weak membrane blocker was used
on the other hand
two little antibodies used coupled with
poor sensitivity a poor sensitivity
substrate will result in faint
undetectable bands as you can see in the
second plot
in the third lot you can see saturated
bands that are burned out likely because
too much secondary antibody was used
together with a fast substrate
and in the last blood at the bottom
there are many non-specific bands which
could be due to poor antibody
specificity too much primary antibody or
insufficient blocking
[Music]
to further understand the importance of
optimizing antibody concentration here
we have performed Western bloating for
HSP 90 a high abundance Target and used
different primary antibody amounts
for all the primary antibody
concentrations
the curved bands due to membrane
saturation
but also notice that when less antibody
is used in the line in green
the curved bending is less pronounced
and this is because antibody binding
interference is avoided
and when antibody concentration is very
high like the line in blue there is even
a drop in Signal due to substrate
burnout because the substrate amount
cannot keep up with the kinetic of the
high levels of hrp present
[Music]
now let's take a look at cycling b a low
abundance Target
here the slight curve in data a is
likely not due to overloading since it
is a low abundance Target
in data B we have diluted primary
antibody by further 10 times and in data
C we have diluted the secondary antibody
by further five times
and for both of these dilutions you can
see there is Improvement in the
linearity of the Curve
when we diluted both the primary and
secondary antibody together
the linearity of the curve was even
better
and this shows that adjusting both
primary and secondary body antibody
amounts results in near perfectly linear
results
however take note that diluting your
antibodies excessively can result in
minor reduction in the limit of
detection for some other targets
[Music]
here we have data showing increasing
dilution of primary antibody for p23
from left to right and in each figure
you can see two dilutions of secondary
antibody in blue and yellow
you can see that with more diluted
secondary antibody the R square is
improved
however when you look at the
corresponding graphs below we should
zoom in on the lowest Target amounts you
notice there is a minor reduction in the
limit of detection
[Music]
another tip is non-proportional ratios
of primary and secondary antibody can
often have good outcomes
so don't just dilute your secondary
antibody
if you are using high primary consider
using low secondary
and if using low primary consider
increasing your secondary antibody
[Music]
one common question with antibodies is
should we be reusing the antibodies
generally reusing antibodies is okay
however you need to bear in mind that
the results will change with each plot
as you can see from the Bloods and the
graph the signal gets weaker each time
the antibody is reused
and so this is not ideal if you are
trying to optimize your Bloods
our recommendation is to start with a
higher dilution of the primary antibody
and use it only once
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
optimizing antibody concentration
choosing the right products for
immunopropine can affect your Western
blood results
thermal fissure scientific offers a wide
portfolio of products for immunopropin
in Western blood detection including a
wide variety of blocking buffers primary
and secondary antibodies validated for
Western blotting and we also offer a
full range of substrates
[Music]
when it comes to detection
traditional chemiluminescence methods
are very widely used and is very
sensitive but for this method the number
of targets you can visualize on the
blood is more limited
fluorescence-based Western blotting
allows you to Multiplex several Targets
on the same lot without the need to
strip and reproach
as such fluorescence Western blotting
can be used to provide more insight into
complex research questions
multiplexing is very useful when looking
at Targets that have the same or are
very close in molecular weight
such as in the figure on the right you
can see that photograph 1 and phosphomat
1 they have the same molecular weight
and the housekeeping protein get the H
which is also very close in molecular
weight
and with fluorescence Western blotting
it is possible to visualize all of these
on the same block
it is also possible to combine chemi and
fluorescence detection on the same lot
next
do substrate kinetics impact
quantitation
in the bloods on the right
we we are we allow Bloods for last 10
a low abundance protein and HSP 90 a
high abundance protein to sit in a small
amount of substrate for extended times
for both low and high abundance bands
the data remains linear over time
however we've overloaded High abundance
targets extended incubation can cause
the substrate to burn out over time
[Music]
therefore
it is important to use the substrate
with the right kinetics depending on the
abundance of your protein
at thermal facial scientific we offer a
range of substrates from the lower
sensitivity on the left to the highest
sensitivity on the right
so you can see that our peers ecl is the
most economical for high abundance
proteins
our super signal West Pico plus
substrate is an excellent everyday
substrate
at the mid-range we have super signal
West Dura which provides long-lasting
signal duration and more flexibility for
both high and low abundant substrates
and for high sensitivity substrates we
have the super signal West femto and our
latest addition to the range is our
super signal West air tool substrate
which gives you the highest signal to
noise ratio
[Music]
here we have benchmarked how super
signal West Dura Pierce ecl and super
signal West at all performs with
different primary and secondary antibody
concentrations on Rust 10 a low
abundance protein
the results show that at high antibody
concentrations
super signal West ATO is way too
sensitive showing a non-linear curve and
signs of burnout
on the other hand when we use the lower
sensitivity option which is the piers
ecl this resulted in exposure times that
were way too long in the low antibody
concentrations
what we notice however is that for super
signal West Dura which has a mid-range
sensitivity it actually performs very
well across different antibody
concentrations showing a linear curve
and fast exposure types
[Music]
interestingly
even with high abundance proteins like
hsb90
super signal West Europe substrate
performs very well across different
antibody concentrations
therefore
substrates with a midpoint insensitivity
such as super signal West Dura substrate
shows more flexibility with different
concentrations of both primary and
secondary antibodies with reasonable
exposure time for both high and low
abundance targets
foreign
aging systems makes image acquisition
and data analysis very easy with a
variety of smart features including
Advanced Auto exposure automatic sample
alignment automated analysis including
quantitation and normalization which can
be performed on board the instrument
the eye bright Imaging system is capable
of multiplexing up to four colors
simultaneously from both visible and
near infrared and even Cami on the same
image
the eyebrow Imaging system allows you to
achieve High sensitivity with an
improved dynamic range
[Music]
and speaking of dynamic range this is
also a consideration when performing
quantitative Western blotting
when choosing your image capture method
note that both film and imaging systems
will saturate when the exposure time is
too long
film however has significantly less
dynamic range compared to an Imaging
system and it will not tell you when
saturation has occurred
on the other hand
Imaging systems they have a wider
dynamic range and may have advanced
algorithms to determine when saturation
has occurred
as you can see in the blood on the right
with the smart exposure technology of
the eyebrow imager it automatically
determines the best exposure time that
is within the images dynamic range with
no saturation
and if you see the manually set exposure
times the I write is also able to
determine that saturation has occurred
shown by the bands in red
[Music]
now some users who are very used to the
film method May argue that film has the
best sensitivity
here is some reference luminometer play
images captured on x-ray field and
ibride imaging system and you can see
that the eyebrow Imaging system is able
to give much better sensitivity than
x-ray film at all exposure times
[Music]
another consideration when performing
quantitative Western blotting is protein
normalization
scientific Publishers and funding
agencies are not requiring other forms
of normalization or validation of
normalization controls to ensure
reproducibility and accuracy of
quantitative Western blotting results
[Music]
keeping proteins are the most commonly
used normalization control
in the table on the right you can see
some commonly used housekeeping proteins
such as actin Gap DH and tubulin
housekeeping proteins are assumed to be
expressed constitutively at the same
levels across experiments
however to reliably use housekeeping
proteins for normalization it is
necessary to validate that firstly your
housekeeping protein is not being
regulated by the experimental condition
and secondly that your housekeeping
protein is within the linear range and
not saturated
foreign
[Music]
the alternative to normalizing to
housekeeping proteins is to perform
total protein normalization
with total protein normalization
the abundance of your target is
normalized to the total amount of
protein in each lane instead of being
dependent on a single loading control
protein
this method is sensitive
you can use as little as 0.1 micrograms
of total protein per Lane
and more importantly it improves data
reliability of quantitative Western
Bloods
one final tip for the immunodection
portion is to check your transfer
consistency before going on to
immunopropin
doing this will ensure that you do not
waste time and antibodies on a bad blood
you can check transfer either by
labeling proteins or by staining them
our in vitrogen no stain protein
labeling reagent labels the proteins
which can later be used to perform total
protein normalization
the labeling takes only 10 minutes is
highly sensitive and the signal is
stable for years
the alternative is to stain the proteins
and for this we have the pears
reversible protein staining kit
however
staining takes slightly longer and is
also slightly less sensitive
and just a note that for those doing
fluorescence Western blotting we
recommend against using ponzio S for
staining as even after washing off it
leaves a background stain on all bands
in several fluores channels
[Music]
when checking transfer
some commonly used tests is to check how
much protein is remaining on the gel and
how much protein has been transferred to
the membrane
however note that not all tests are
indicative of good Western results
in the word transfer on the left you can
see there is little protein left on the
gel and most including the very high
molecular weight bands are transferred
onto the membrane
however after the block is processed
many bands of Interest are missing
on the other hand with the fast dry
transfer using our iblo 2 system you
still see a lot of protein left on the
gel pulse transfer and a good amount is
transferred to the membrane
however when the blood is processed you
are able to see all the bands of
Interest nicely
[Music]
so what this means is a clean gel does
not always mean good results
when a Gel looks very clean
it also means that significant over
transfer could occur
additionally
over transfer may cause protein to bind
weakly to the membrane
such that there is partially such that
it is partially removed in immunopropy
and as mentioned before protein stacking
on the membrane can affect linearity
so the bottom line is the protein amount
membrane transfer time and voltage and
buffers used can have an impact on how
well a protein binds to a membrane
this can influence if anything washes
off the membrane in immunopropine
oh I'll go to fast dry transfer system
has optimized protocols to ensure that
the most efficient transfer of your
molecular weights of Interest without
over transfer
[Music]
in summary
in order to achieve reliable
quantitative data from the Western plots
and to avoid experimental variations of
optimization controls and normalization
are required to prove the accuracy of
your results
this can be achieved by
using a low gel load amount to prevent
membrane saturation
confirming transfer consistency by
membrane labeling or staining
normalization using housekeeping genes
or total protein
[Music]
and ensuring no image saturation by
using an imager with a high dynamic
range
[Music]
at Thermo efficient scientific we have a
wide library of educational resources at
our protein gel electrophoresis and
Western blotting education center to
help you with every aspect of Western
blood analysis and these include how-to
videos tips and tricks on-demand videos
and our latest Technologies and also
protocols and these can all be accessed
at our web page
thermofisher.com Western education
[Music]
so that brings me to the end of my
presentation thank you very much for
your time and I will hand the time back
to you Megan
[Music]
thank you Dr Audrey and Anthony Lim for
your informative presentation before we
go to our live q a we would like to draw
your attention to the left side of your
screen where you will find a survey on
today's webinar
we will now allow a few minutes for you
to fill out that survey before getting
to the Q a thank you
thank you all so much for taking the
time to complete the survey we will now
begin our q a portion of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
ask a question box and click Send we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
let's get started our first question is
for you Anthony
what are the pros and cons of using
fluorescent conjugated secondary versus
enzyme conjugated secondary antibodies
foreign
[Music]
thanks for the question so Frozen
conjugated secondary antibody allows the
multiplexing technique to be involved
here and in this case here they are
commonly used in techniques such as
frauds dormitory immuno fluorescence
immunocytochemistry cellular Imaging
furthermore Frozen dies typically have
wider dynamic range as well
which allows more quantitative analysis
in reverse the enzyme link secondary
antibody allows calorimetric as well as
chemiluminescence detection of the
primary antibody body and they are
widely used in techniques such as
Western broadening amino acids including
elisas
great thank you so much Audrey my next
question is for you
um how do the labeling reagents stains
work do they bind to the proteins and if
so are they compatible with their
Downstream steps such as blocking
antibody binding Etc
so that's a great question yeah so I
went through labeling as well as
staining earlier so labeling right in
the context of the no stain reagent that
I mentioned that we have for total
protein normalization so how that works
is they actually forms covalent bonds
with the uh lysine amino acid residues
which is the most abundant in protein so
these covalent bonds they are actually
permanent so that means that you know
for all the downstream steps it doesn't
get washed off throughout the
immunopropine
yeah so that actually allows you to do
the total protein normalization later on
after all the antibody incubation
on the other hand staining it actually
stains the proteins but that is also
reversible
okay so what this means is that yeah
usually you will wash it off before
going on to immunopropine yeah but even
then uh with the immunoprotein
the
blocking and the antibody steps and all
that it will get washed off so the
membrane stain the stain in protein
staining is really mainly for checking
the transfer efficiency whereas for the
labeling it can be used for Downstream
total protein normalization as the
signal you know it stays on permanently
yeah great thank you so much and just as
a reminder to our audience if you have
any questions to ask this will now be
your time to do so
um but that brings me to my next
question which is for you Anthony
um can you further elaborate on
um what is Advanced verified antibodies
how is that different with non-varied
antibodies
great question here thanks
so uh just to elaborate a bit further um
in common pleasure scientific our
antibodies are typically undergoes a
rigorous two-part testing approach so on
the first part uh which is known as
targets versus City verification uh this
step will help to ensure that the
antibody will bind to the correct Target
in this case here our antibodies are
being tested using at least one of the
following method which I shared earlier
just to ensure proper functionality in
the researchers experiment this will
include techniques like knockout
knock down of the protein or independent
antibody verification
which uh is like measuring the target
expression
by performing or using two different uh
differentially uh race antibody that
recognizes the same protein Target
cellular treatment relative protein
expression neutralization and so forth
so this is the first part and on the
second part we perform functional
application verification where these
tests are used to help to ensure that
the antibody Works in a particular
application of interest and this may
include like Western broading that we
shared today for cytometry chromatin
immunoprecipitation
immunofluorocin Imaging as well as
immunocytokemistry
so this is the two-step approach that we
take within the company just to ensure
that the empty body that we provide are
the of the highest quality to ensure
that the researcher has the best tool in
their hands
thank you
thank you
Audrey my next question is for you why
is linear response important for
quantitation in Western blotting
so thank you for the question
okay so yes so in my presentation you
know I keep emphasizing on this linear
response uh in order to get accurate
with uh quantitative results in Western
body yeah because this linear response
is really the whole basis of doing the
quantitation in Western blotting right
so the assumption is that as my protein
load increases right my signal is going
to increase as well so if the if the
response is not linear it's saturating
right then you're not going to get
accurate results you are you won't be
able to tell if what the gene expression
is really different or not and
especially this is especially important
for housekeeping proteins right
housekeeping input things are usually
very abundant and have a high tendency
to saturate so this is really something
that yeah you should bear in mind when
doing the quantitative Western blotting
right when you're trying to come compare
if one gene has
is more expressed than another
right so that's that is why you know in
my presentation I actually talk um a lot
about give a lot of tips on how to
prevent that saturation right like don't
don't overload your proteins very very
important don't overload your antibodies
choose uh image with a white dynamic
range choose the right substrate and so
on all of these tips are really you know
to ensure that ensure the linearity of
that signal
great thank you and it looks like we
have one more question here Audrey what
are some pharmaceutical industry
industrial applications of Western
blotting
[Music]
okay so in terms of industrial
applications yeah so like if uh let's
say in the pharmaceutical industry so a
lot of times they're actually
synthesizing proteins right so Western
blotting is one way to verify that they
are indeed getting their proteins of
Interest
right and if you know Downstream they're
also looking at you know how this
protein is going to
um you know in the r d phase right how
this protein is going to uh affect the
entire workflow uh response right
Downstream then Western blotting can
actually also give an indication of what
is being upregulated down regulated and
so on
great thank you and another question we
have here as you mentioned Audrey that
the labeling reagent works with covalent
bonds with lysine amino acids is there a
minimum number of Lysine amino acids a
protein needs to have for the labeling
reagent to work
yeah that's a great question yeah so the
reason why you know when when R D team
develops is an on-state reagent and yeah
why we chose lysine is because we know
that lysine is one of the most abundant
amino acids so with this in mind yeah
you don't really need to be so concerned
that whether there is a minimum number
of Lysine amino acids in your protein
because it is most likely going to be
the most abundant one there
yeah so on the other hand if you are
working with other types of labeling
reagents that's maybe label other types
of amino acid then you know you have to
be concerned that like for example like
tryptophan residues that are not so uh
not so abundant yeah then you have to
yeah check whether your protein has
sufficient amount for it to be accurate
for normalization
[Music]
great thank you so much Audrey thank you
both so much do you have any final
comments for our audience tonight
foreign
let me start by sharing that you know
um protein analysis is a widely used
technique in the field of biologics
right so a lot of the protein or
antibodies which are being used uh
currently are also therapeutic drugs as
well like you know the use of colon
antibody to treat cancer as well so the
ability to analyze to make sure that
your protein are intact the protein are
expressed at an appropriate level is a
very good technique and it's also a very
good methodology to ensure that you know
what goes into the patient uh of good
quality
and for my side I would say that you
know a thermal facial scientific we are
really committed to transform the way
you perform Western blotting to improve
your results keep you know you know get
your results in a much faster time yeah
so do not hesitate to you know reach out
to your nearest uh thermal facial rep
yeah so we'll be very happy to share
with you you know what are the latest
technologies that we have that can
improve your results
great thank you again Dr Audrey Lynn and
Dr Anthony Lim for your time today and
your important research we would also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye
[Music]